25 يوما من الصراع في السودان الاوضاع لا
تزال على حاله لا بل تزداد سوءا لاسيما
الاوضاع الانسانيه منها انتشال وانتشار
كبير لحالات السطو والنهب والسرقات في
المناطق التي تتركز فيها الاشتباكات
بالعاصمه الخرطوم مستغلين طبعا نزوح سكان
تلك المناطق خوفا من الاشتباكات كما تعرضت
هنا مشاهدينا الكثير من الاسواق والمحال
التجاريه للسرقه جراء الانفلات الامنيه ما
دفع طبعا المواطنين الى البحث عن حلول
لتامين احيائهم وممتلكاتهم بانفسهم
المنظمات الامميه هي الاخرى لم تسلم من
السرقات اذ تعرض مجمع رئيسي لبرنامج
الاغذيه العالميه في العاصمه السودانيه
للنهب والصدقه وفق تاكيدات الامم المتحده
اما ميدانيا فقد فشل كل من الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في الالتزام باتفاقات
الهدنه المتكرره حيث تتواصل المعارك بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في الخرطوم مع سماع
طبعا ذوي انفجارات عنيفه وغارات جويه وسط
العاصمه فيما اكدت قوات الدعم السريع بان
القصر الرئاسي اصيب بضربه قويه جراء طبعا
غارات للجيش وهنا مشاهدينا اشار مراسل
العربيه الى رص طلعات مكثفه لطيران الجيش
السوداني وذوي اسلحه ثقيله شرقي مدينه ام
درمان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات